[Music]  insurance company AIG remember them they  got a hundred and eighty two billion  dollars from the US government in the  financial bailout a couple years ago  well they've been considering  considering a lawsuit against the United  States why cuz they don't like the terms  of the bailout this yes unbelievable it  is shocking what's even more shocking is  the commercial AIG just put out they say  it's to thank America for the bailout  money I I don't think they're helping  their image any here AIG we said we're  gonna turn it around and we did we're  now leaner and focused on what we do  best  plus a profit of more than twenty two  billion we turned it around America  [Applause]  why are you cheering for that  Nosa self-loathing crowd I'd ever come  across